[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
I want to start
with this sort of big
picture, all right.
So we're going to kind of
introduce energy storage,
and then we'll talk about sort
of why electrical storage is
kind of a thing and
important, and then
we'll kind of go into
batteries and then
talk about the
chemistry of batteries
and throw in a couple
of, why this matters.
So if you think about
this on a planetary scale,
actually, the planet is
kind of a storage device.
It's an energy storage device
for that thing over there,
right, and so like if you think
about all the energy flows that
go on on planet
Earth, well, then
you've got-- there's
a picture I like.
It kind of shows you the
different energy flows, right.
You've got the sun, so you've
got like solar radiation.
You've got tides, there's
the moon, you've got wind.
You've got all these
kinds of energy happening
on the planet, all the way
down to life happening, rock
formation, right.
And then sometimes
those things, you know,
rocks can form alloys over
millions and millions of years.
And the thing is, if
you think about this,
where you draw the line is
somewhat arbitrary in a sense,
right.
It depends on our use.
I mean, if you think
about it, fossil fuels
are actually a renewable source
of energy on geological scales.
The problem is
that it's like 10,
20, 30 million year
old sunlight, right,
and it'll happen
again, but the question
is how do we store energy on
timescales that matter to us.
And so you can draw
this line and then
think about what that means,
and typically, most sort
of energy storage
needs are going
to be around a year
or less, right.
OK, so now why electricity?
Why electricity, right.
So the thing is,
electricity is more and more
important in our
lives, and if you
look at just sort of
like the major sectors,
so you have the
power generation,
you have transportation,
you have industry,
you have buildings, and this
is a plot of these sectors
and the CO2 emissions.
You can plot all sorts of
things about these sectors.
This is CO2 versus time.
These are kind of the
major contributors,
but the thing is electricity,
because of things
that are happening as well, the
opportunity-- either the use
of electricity now like
power to your home,
or the opportunity
to use it a lot more
later, like transportation,
that means that electricity has
sort of about a 70% role,
about a 70% opportunity of all
of this.
That's how much
electricity matters here,
but the thing is
that electricity,
as you know, in an
electric car it's not
going to be useful if you
have to have it plugged
in all the time, right.
And so most of this 70%, most of
this 70%, I want to emphasize,
is not currently--
it's the potential
for the electrification of
our world that is happening.
That's how much electricity
will play a role, but most of it
is useless unless you can store
it, so storage of electricity
is clearly really,
really important.
And so we get to sort of how
do you think about storage
technologies, and again, I
just want to kind of gently
introduce us to energy storage
and we'll go into batteries.
Now so the kind of plot that
I'm showing you here, talking
about Ashby plots, right,
but this is actually
a different kind.
It's a special kind because it
has to do with energy storage,
and there's a guy who in the
1960s, David Ragone, he first--
And it's actually fascinating.
He wrote a paper
in 1968, a review
of batteries for electric
vehicles in 1968, right.
And he's saying, how
do I put-- there's
all these possibilities.
We want to electrify our
transportation fleet,
but which batteries
make the most sense?
And so he decided to plot
them on these two axes,
energy stored versus the power
and that's a very common way.
These are called
Ragone plots now,
so it's the energy versus power.
And this is how you'll
see a lot of discussions.
If you look online and you're
interested in energy storage
as a field, you'll
see a lot of plots
like this where you got, OK,
so energy is like watt hours,
right.
For example, this would
be like watts times hours
and this would be
like the watts.
So one of the nice things
about plots like this,
mostly, it's always
on a log scale
so you can stretch out and see
all the different technologies
on one plot, right.
And one of the nice things about
a plot is that this is energy,
this is energy, and this
is energy per time, right.
And so that's energy
per time times
time, so we can have
lots of fun with that.
But so what that means if you
think about it a little bit,
if you plot energy storage
technologies on plots
like this, then these diagonal
lines are one number of time.
It's like if you
had a given density
and you're using
it at a given rate,
a giving power, then that's
how long it would last.
So these plots are
really convenient.
They're really convenient ways
to compare energy technologies.
OK, so those would be like, I've
got energy storage technology
and it's got this much density,
this much power-- well,
then it's going to last if I
use it at that power for 41 days
and so forth.
Now the interesting, though,
there's lots of stuff on here.
Why don't I just
want high and high?
That sounds like a
good thing, right,
so shouldn't we be pumping water
up hills all over the place?
Well, obviously, if
you think about it,
you don't do that in your phone.
You don't even do
that in your backyard.
that in a town.
Why?
Because pumped hydro is
extraordinarily limited.
You have to do it at
very large scales.
It's very low energy
density, right.
It's geographically
highly constrained.
It is one of the oldest ways we
have of storing energy, right.
I'm just thinking
of the waterwheel,
but it's very constrained,
so we can't use this in most
applications, pumped hydro.
But OK, oh, so this
is compressed air.
Compressed Air, CAES.
That sounds good.
That's got a whole lot
of limitations as well.
We've got, just to give
you the abbreviations,
Superconducting Magnetic Coils.
Superconducters, right,
just keep it going.
And then you draw the
[MUMBLES] and it just
keeps going forever.
It's a great battery, right,
except for all the problems
that it has and
how much it costs,
but it's a really cool
concept and it's here.
All of these things exist.
They all exist and they're all
very interesting and important
energy storage devices.
They're interesting, important,
electrical energy storage
devices, right.
So that's the main point.
So like here, you
know supercaps,
you build up a lot
of charge in a solid.
Here you've got flywheels.
Well, I'm just rotating
something heavy really,
really fast.
I get worried about that.
I don't want to be
in that building,
but they do build flywheel
energy storage device where
you slow it down and then you
generate electricity from that.
So these kinds of plots
are really, really,
really helpful for comparing one
energy technology with another.
Now, the thing is as I said,
there's a whole list of these
and it goes on and on.
Oh, that's really hard to see.
They've all got a lot of
limitations, all right,
and so capacitors
have a low density.
You can convert
energy into some fuel
and store it and
then combust it.
That's got low
round-trip efficiency.
This is what we're going to talk
about today, electrochemical.
There are challenges there too.
Kinetic, pumped hydro,
there's so many different ways
of storing energy.
The thing is there
is an advantage
that I want to mention about
using electrochemistry.
There is an advantage about
using electrochemistry,
and what is electro--
I just said the word
electrochemistry.
I should tell you
what that is, right,
and it's the relationship
between electricity
and chemical reactions.
I love saving time, rxns.
That's equal to
electrochemistry.
This isn't it.
Now electrochemistry, OK.
And so what you'll
see is like things
like electrochemical
energy storage,
and this isn't just
one type of thing.
It's not just one
type of battery.
It's not even just batteries.
It's this broader
definition, but we're going
to talk about batteries today.
Now, so there's something
else that's really useful.
So I mentioned we're
getting to the point
where we're
electrifying everything.
We need electricity
almost everywhere,
even in your combustion car.
You need electricity a
lot more than you used to,
than 20 years ago.
And so as we
electrify our world,
and then I said I've got
to store that energy,
you start to think
about what Carnot did.
Now I'm paraphrasing here,
but this is basically
what he said if you think
about how it applies
to this conversion, which
is that the second law
of thermodynamics makes
you pay a penalty of energy
if you convert it into heat
and then back into electricity.
Well, even if you just have
heat in the first place
and now you want to generate
electricity from that,
you're limited.
We talked about
this before, right,
like that the energy density
of gasoline, it's so high
and it's such an amazing energy
storage material because you
can transport it safely, right.
Yeah, but the thing is, I just
gave you the example the car.
You put it in your car.
Does anybody know how efficient,
how much of that energy
your car actually uses
to move percentage wise?
Take a guess?
Yeah, it's 10% to 20%,
maybe, 10% to 20%.
It depends on the car--
my car probably 5%.
It's an old car.
So most of that gasoline's
energy is going into waste.
Why?
Carnot.
Now this is not a
thermodynamics class,
but this comes into
this so I wanted
to mention Carnot and the
fact that there is another way
to do it.
So you could do chemical
reaction to heat.
That's how we power
most of our world today.
A power plant gets up
to a higher temperature
so the penalty is less, but
still most power plants,
you lose about 50%.
Most power plants at
best are around 50%
efficient in terms of
converting the thermal energy
into electrical energy.
Yeah, but I can use
a different way,
and that's electrochemistry.
And it's one of the reasons
why electrochemical energy
storage is so appealing, because
you don't really pay a penalty.
You don't really pay a penalty.
I can go back and forth without
the second law hurting me.
So I want to mention
something about Carnot,
about the second law, and again,
this is not a class on thermo,
but the second law
involves entropy
so I had to say something,
especially because it's
in Averill, right, and that's
your textbook that you're
diligently reading every
day, and there it is.
And by the way, Averill
has a beautiful chapter
on batteries, chapter 19.
I'm sure you know.
It's really well written.
This is what he says
about entropy, though,
and for now we can
state that entropy
is a thermodynamic property
of all substances that
is proportional to their
degree of disorder.
Averill, such a good book, but
let me ask you guys a question.
So people think about
entropy as disorder
and they think about entropy
as sort of more disorder.
Let me ask you,
which one of these
has a higher entropy,
the one on the left
or the one on the right?
So how many of you think
the one on the left
has a higher entropy?
How many of you think
it's the one on the right?
So the thing is it's
the one on the left.
Yeah, right.
I love that you
guys are blown away.
Why?
Because entropy is not
about smoothness and it's
not about disorder.
That is wrong.
Entropy is about
accessibility to states.
It's about how many
states you have to be in.
Now, that can appear to
be like disorder, right,
but a messier room does
not have higher entropy,
and in this case,
it's just simply
the rules of the algorithm.
I have rules here about the dots
being able to touch each other.
They are randomly selected but
with the constraint that they
cannot touch each other.
That means that those dots
had fewer possibilities.
They had fewer states
that they could be in.
This system has
much higher entropy.
It's about the number of states.
I just want to make that--
again, this is not the
topic of this class,
but I've got to make my case
about entropy when I can.
And I brought up
Carnot, so there you go.
Entropy is not just disorder.
Now OK, so we're
back to batteries.
Now so electrochemistry,
there's a lot
of reasons why
electrochemical storage is--
here's the chart again, right.
It's this one here.
You see that, electrochemical
batteries, all right,
that we're going to talk about.
There's a lot of reasons
why this is so appealing.
No penalty on the second
law is one of them.
You can have transport
easily, right.
We drive electric cars.
We see that.
No pollution at the
point of use-- pollution
can be focused at the
point of production.
Also, the batteries
can be charged
by renewable technologies
like solar wind,
and they're very
highly efficient.
Electric cars, for example,
have a very high efficiency
depending on the car,
but upwards of 90%
in terms of converting
that electrical energy back
and forth.
The metrics that matter, I
wrote a couple of them here,
all right, watts, hours.
These are the things
that matter in batteries,
but so many other things
matter, and this is why
this is a complicated problem.
And it's also why batteries
are not in any way
a one-size-fits-all.
I mean, you know that from
like AAs and AAAs and 9-volt,
but it's so much more
than that, because it's
about the application change
not going from your computer
to your phone but going
from your car to your phone
to a house to a grid.
And so the needs are all
going to be different,
and then which ones of
these things you care about
is going to depend on what
chemistry you think about.
It all comes down
to the chemistry
as we're going to see.
It's all about the chemistry.
And just to put a
few numbers down,
the cell phone has a
few watts of power.
Light bulb is 10 to 100.
A AAA battery has 1.5
watt hours of storage,
all right, so that's how
much energy is inside
of a AAA battery.
Needed to drive a car 200
miles, 100 kilowatt hours.
It's just fun to think
about these things, right.
Powering your
house, 40 kilowatts
max, depending on how many
AC units you're running.
The world is this many
watts as of a few years ago.
So if you had, I
think it's something
like 20,000 billion
AAA batteries,
you could run the world for an
hour-ish, something like that.
These numbers are
just fun to play with,
so I wanted to put
a few examples down.
So where'd it all begin?
It all began with an argument.
It all began with this
beautiful argument
that I have to tell
you because it's really
a cool piece of history.
And it took place in Italy.
And it was Galvani who
was a physiologist,
and he really loved the topic
of why animals move, right.
So what is motion?
How is it that
animals are moving?
You know, how am I
moving my muscles?
How is anything moving?
Well, there had been
theories about this
going all the way back.
You remember Socrates and
Plato, the elements, right,
and aether?
There were similar theories
for motion of the human body.
In fact, the word
pneuma was used
to describe the essence that
goes through all living things
that allows them to move.
Well, Galvani didn't
like that and he
wanted something more
concrete, and so he was really
trying to make a
connection, especially
between things that
move and electricity.
Now, it was difficult. There
wasn't like a constant source.
So you had electric generators
in your lab at the time,
but Galvani wanted to go big, so
he hooked up his lightning rod
to a frog.
The frog was not alive.
Well, the frog was
not alive, seriously,
because then you'll see why--
at least I don't think so.
I really hope not.
Now I'm thinking about it,
I'm getting a little bummed
honestly, but I don't
think they were alive.
That doesn't look alive.
So he hooked them up to
lightning rods and he watched
and he waited as the storm's
coming, and he's like,
the lightning rod hits and he
hooked him up to some metals,
and the frog went crazy.
It was like, ah-ha,
motion, electricity.
He'd been jolting
them in his lab
with his own electric generator,
but he wanted to go big,
and also, they didn't know.
They didn't know at the time
what electricity was, right,
so they didn't know if the
electricity that he generated
in his own thing was the
same as the electricity that
came from the sky.
He saw that you get the same
result. The frog still moved.
So Galvani said the
motion of a frog,
and all motion of
all living creatures,
generates electricity.
That's what he said.
He deduced that
the motion itself
is something that
generates electricity.
This is a really cool little
article about this debate,
because in Galvani's case,
if you have two metal wires
hooked up to a frog, like we
say, if you close the loop,
then what he said is that
the charge that was already
in there moves around
the loop and back
and makes the leg move.
Volta got really interested
in this and he said, you know,
let me study this.
He was a physicist at
the time and he said,
this looks fascinating,
let me study it--
but he said, you
know, why do you keep
using two different metals?
So I think this is about
the metals, not the frog,
and they had a big
huge argument, right.
So this is Volta's
picture, is that it's
when you connect two
different metals that you
get a charge flowing
through the frog.
Volta, I think, as
many of you know,
went on to win that
argument, and we
have the volt named
after him, and he also
created the first stable
battery, the voltaic pile.
Galvani on the other hand really
opened the doors to the idea
that we have electricity in our
bodies, which is pretty cool.
He also is the reason why
the story of Frankenstein
was written.
It's actually true because
they went around and took
all sorts of things and
electrocuted them and showed
that they moved, and
often they weren't alive,
and so Mary Shelley,
I think, saw that.
You went around like the
countryside shocking people,
and I actually meant that
as like not literally,
but just shocking them
by what he's doing.
And I don't think
they ever used humans,
but still, people's
imaginations and so forth,
and it was quite a thing.
OK, very interesting story.
Now, why does this matter?
I've got two why this matters.
Today my first one is on a
personal scale, smaller scale,
and then my next one
is on a grid scale.
So this is called a little sun.
There's over a
billion people who
can't read at night
because there's
no access to electricity,
and of course,
a lot of the studying
that you could do
would be at night, right.
So this is a really
cool program.
Why does this work?
This is a solar cell
but this wouldn't
work unless you could store
the electricity, right,
so I wanted to make you
guys aware of Little Sun.
You just press this and you
can read at night, right.
This is already making
a big difference
in millions of people's lives.
That doesn't happen
unless you've
got electrochemical
energy storage,
right, and there's
some stats up here.
$25 billion liters
of kerosene are
used to meet the basic lighting
needs in a lot of these places.
That releases tremendous
amounts of toxic fumes,
and you can make
a huge difference,
But you know, it's sort of
the same as cooking, right.
So wood fire cooking
is a huge problem.
So the challenge is,
but you don't cook.
If you have a solar
cooker, that's
great except that most people
don't cook during the day.
They cook at night or
in the morning, right.
And so you've got
to store energy
to make these things
actually useful, right,
and I really like
this program so I
wanted to make that one
of my, why this matters.
And we'll go big
on the next one,
but let's get to the chemistry.
So what happens in a battery?
The best way to understand
this is with a classic example
of two different metals.
It's Volta's two
different metals.
Volta did lots of metals.
That's what he did.
And he showed that the frog
moved with most of them,
so it's the metals.
So let's take these two classic
metals and show what happens.
You've got copper
and you've got zinc.
Now, in this case, I'm
just going to have a zinc.
This is the zinc piece of metal,
and this is a piece of zinc,
and I put it in a
solution of copper ions.
And so in this case,
what do we have?
Let's write this down.
In this case, I've
got zinc solid.
Well, before I write this
down, let's write down
what's in the solution.
The solution is copper sulfate
and this goes to everything
that we've been talking about.
So I've got a
solution, a beaker,
that has copper ions in it.
How much?
I don't know.
Look up the K sp, right?
Now we know how to do that.
So 2 minus in solution.
So you put some of this copper
sulfate powder in that beaker.
It turns blue and it
gives you these ions that
are dissolved in solution, and
then you put a piece of zinc
in there.
So what happens is there is a
transfer of electrons, right.
Now we talked a lot
about electrons.
We're talking about
transfers of electrons.
I mean, just think
about it, right.
We went from H,
right, like this.
Look at that, right, the bonding
and then we did this, OK.
Here we go.
It's a little bit less
sharing but still.
All right, and then we did
this, where it's like, OK,
there's almost nothing there.
It all went there.
These are where my
electrons are, all right.
Well, then we put this in
water and we got this, OK.
And we got them
sort of separated
and this one just broke
off with its electron,
leaving a positive
charge behind.
So we've done all this.
We know this, all right.
So what's happening
here is special
because what's happening here
is a trading of electrons.
You see, in all the
bonding that we've done,
we're talking about how
electrons share in bonds
and then these
things break apart,
but now I'm going to do
reactions that trade them.
That's electrochemistry.
That's electrochemistry,
and what
happens when I put that zinc
strip into that solution
is this.
The zinc that goes into solution
is 2 plus and 2 electrons.
And the copper in
the solution plates
onto the zinc, plus
those 2 electrons
goes to copper like that.
And if you look at
the full reaction,
the full reaction would be
then zinc solid plus copper
2 plus in solution goes to zinc
2 plus in solution plus copper
solid.
That's the trading.
Now I like writing it like
this because you really
see explicitly the gaining
and losing of electrons.
Oh, those have words
associated with them,
gaining and losing electrons.
But this is the
reaction that we're
kind of used to, right, so
this is just the same thing.
It's what happens, right.
It's what happens.
It's a trade of electrons.
Now it turns out that
when something loses
electrons like that
we call it oxidation,
and when something
gains electrons
we call this reduction.
And so when two
different materials--
in this case, these two metals--
trade electrons and one of them
is oxidized and one
of them is reduced,
that's also got a name.
It's called a redox couple.
Those are a redox couple,
redox, redox, right.
So these are a redox couple,
is what they're called when
you trade electrons like this.
OK, so what's happening?
What's happening is at
the surface of the zinc,
I see these copper
ions in solution.
And it's like, well, if
I gave you two electrons,
then you'd be able to become
a copper solid, right.
So if I give you two electrons,
you're a copper solid,
but now if I lose two
electrons as a zinc atom,
I'm a zinc 2 plus.
That's this.
That's just this, right.
Why does that happen?
Well, we'll get to that, right,
but that's what's happening.
So a zinc atom at
the surface, all
right, a zinc atom at the
service sees a copper 2 plus
and it says here,
have 2 electrons.
Oh, and then it's
like, wait a second.
I gave two electrons away.
I've got to go into solution.
And that's exactly what
you see over here, right.
The copper is plating
the zinc and the zinc
is coming off of the strip.
They're doing this.
All right, why is
that happening?
Because if you put that
strip in there and the thing
just heats up,
this is exothermic.
That means that this
reaction will go.
This is spontaneous.
Where can I write that?
Nowhere.
Spontaneous.
It didn't have to be, as
we'll see, but this one is.
But all that's happening is
you're going down in energy.
You're giving energy
away and you're
heating up the environment.
Now the question is, how
can I not let that happen?
How can I stop the
heating from happen
and instead take advantage
of this electron trading
to do work?
That's what a battery is.
It's taking advantage of this.
And really what it
comes down to is just
a different construction
of the device.
It's this.
The
Fundamentals of a battery
is this kind of thing,
but now instead of allowing
this plating to happen,
I'm going to
separate that and I'm
going to construct
it in such a way
that those electrons get
traded through some wire
that I can do work with, OK.
So for example-- where is it?
OK, maybe not for example.
Maybe for example, maybe I
need to turn this on and off.
Here we go.
This is the picture that
Averill gives for the battery.
So what you saw wasn't a battery
because I wasn't stopping
the electron flow
and doing anything,
but if you construct
it like this,
is called a galvanic cell.
All right, if you
construct it like this,
now I can do work with
that electron trade.
I can do work with
the electron trade.
That's the difference.
So let's go through this.
So on the left,
so what did I do?
Well, I got my zinc strip but
now I've got a copper strip.
Just trying to see.
OK, I've got a copper
strip over here.
I've got a zinc strip over here.
But I'm putting the
zinc not into the copper
directly where I just short
it and the whole thing
just heats up.
Instead, I'm putting the zinc
into a solution of zinc ions.
Look at that.
Zinc has zinc ions
in solution, right.
Now, copper, copper is in
a solution of copper ions.
So these are now
the two beakers.
On the left I've
got zinc nitrate.
In this case it's a
nitrate, not a sulfate.
It doesn't matter.
The whole point
of the solution is
that I get these
ions in a beaker.
Got to get these
ions in a beaker,
so you've got the copper
ions in a beaker on the right
with the copper solid and
you've got the zinc ions.
So let's look at
what's happening
and blow up those
different sides, right.
So at the anode,
it's called the anode
because it's where
the charge comes from.
It's called the anode.
What's happening?
Well, what's happening is
what I just showed you.
The zinc is leaving the solid.
The zinc is leaving the solid
and it's becoming 2 plus.
It's becoming 2 plus.
But the thing is that now,
you've got to be careful here.
So the zinc is becoming 2 plus.
What about those two electrons?
Where do they go?
A zinc atom leaves
its metal strip
and goes into that beaker
of zinc ions, right.
But now you've got two charges,
two electrons on the strip
because it left a zinc 2 plus.
Nothing more will happen.
Nothing more will happen unless
those 2 electrons go away.
That's the whole point.
What's so cool
about batteries is
that it's all about neutrality.
If you think about batteries
as current flowing,
batteries is all
about neutrality.
It's all about keeping
these things neutral
because if I just build
this charge up here,
I can't have another
zinc atom go in
so the charge has
to go somewhere,
but that's what
that wire is for.
That's what this
wire is for, right.
This wire allows the
charge to go over
to the other place,
the cathode, where
the copper is sitting there
saying, you know what,
if I had two electrons--
if I had two electrons
on the copper strip then
I could use those as a way
to lure in a copper 2 plus
ion, right.
I could use those
as a way to lure it.
And if I did that, then I'm
doing what this did right here.
It's the same thing that we
just did with the plating
except now those electrons
are going through this wire
up here.
The zinc is trading
electrons with the copper.
That's keeping this neutral,
so now the electrons go away
and now another zinc
can go into solution.
Then the copper grabs them,
plates a piece of copper,
and then more electrons
can come, right.
It's the same thing.
This is what it looks like.
If you take those electrodes
out of the solutions
after running this for five, 10
minutes, look at what happened.
The copper plated.
You got copper
ions from solution
plating that and zinc ions
from solution leaving that.
And so those are the
reactions that are happening.
One's happening on the
zinc side and one's
happening on the other side,
but there's something else.
There's something else
because there's just
one other piece
of it that you've
got to understand to
understand how a battery works,
and it's this thing here.
So up here, this is my
conduit for electrons to go.
Each time it goes, I can plate.
I can lose the more
it goes, right.
But notice if I lose 2 plus--
so I've got these 2 plus.
It's not charged.
Look at this.
Copper sulfate in that
case is copper nitrate.
Copper sulfate
goes in a solution,
it's not a charged solution.
These things are balanced,
right, 2 plus, 2 minus.
So now I'm taking only a
2 plus out of solution.
No way.
It's the same thing.
You've got make it
neutral again, all right.
It won't work otherwise.
You can't start building
up charge in the solution.
So that's what this
thing is about.
That's what this is.
This is called a salt bridge
and that completes the circuit.
See, this lets the
electrons flow.
This gives ions.
It doesn't matter
what it is, right.
That's the electrolyte.
It's just a source of ions.
Here is an ACL.
It's an ACL, so now
for every copper 2
plus that plates onto the copper
electrode, two NA plus atoms go
into this beaker
from the bridge,
because here I've got
dissolved salt. Dissolved salt,
sodium chloride is in water,
so I got all these sodium ions.
I got all these chlorine ions.
And when a charge imbalance
happens because something
plates here, I can draw sodium
atoms out of the salt bridge
and I can draw chlorine atoms
out of that side, right.
That completes your circuit.
That's an iron neutralizer,
the salt bridge,
and this is allowing
the electrons
to keep everything
neutral, and that's
how you get the current, right.
It's pretty cool.
It's pretty cool stuff.
Now the thing is, you
can do this yourself.
That's why I bought these
for, is that you can--
somebody sees the
the potato battery.
I like the human battery.
So these are just volt
meters and these are
set to the right thing, yep.
And what you'll find, you
can see what happens, right.
Like when you touch the two
electrodes, yeah, and sometimes
you've got to squeeze.
Oh, look at that current.
You have electric-- you
are providing electricity.
You are the salt bridge.
You are the bridge, so
what that means is you
are actually plating and
taking metals off of these two
electrodes right now.
Your hands are doing that
and you're trading electrons.
You're a conduit for
that to happen, right.
You're the salt bridge.
It's pretty cool, and
you can play with these.
You know, you have volt meters.
You have lots of items
on the table tomorrow
maybe at a dinner, and I'm just
suggesting that you play around
with this idea, because look.
This is what Volta did.
This is literally what the
name of that device, the guy
that that's named after,
this is what he did.
He hooked up two
different metals.
I just put some paper
clips in there, it works.
It can be almost--
not almost, but lots of
different metals will work.
Why?
We'll get to that in a sec.
Here I've got another
paperclip and a copper wire,
right, two different metals.
The power isn't coming from
you as Galvani thought.
No, the power is coming
from the difference
in potentials of those
metals wanting or not
wanting electrons.
Everybody wants electrons,
let's be honest, but who wants
its more?
It all comes back to the
same stuff we talked about.
It's just that now we're
talking about the metals
and whether they're more
interested than the other metal
in having those two electrons.
That's what a potential is.
Oh, now so OK.
Here we go.
There's the volt. So what
determines it, right?
What determines the potential?
Well, it's what I just said.
You know, intuitively,
it's the difference
in these things
wanting and saying,
well, OK, I got copper and zinc.
How do I know?
Well, if you look at zinc--
let me see.
Where do I have it?
Here we go.
Zinc, I want to make
sure I get this right.
So zinc is argon
and 3d10 and 4s2.
All right, OK, copper, oh,
we got numbers 30 and 29.
Copper is the same
thing in terms
of its argon core, 3d10 4s1.
Which one of those wants
to give up 2 electrons
or take 2 electrons
more than the other?
That's what determines
the potential.
And you know, when
you look at this,
you might say-- this is
from Averill so he actually
is missing the f's because
this is just taken right
from the textbook, but anyway,
so that's the potential.
Look at this.
This is like an energy diagram
but these aren't electronics.
These are just potentials,
but the potential
is related to which one
wants the 2 electrons more.
It's 2 plus.
The oxidation state is 2
plus, so you look at this,
you say, well, I
don't know which one
might give up electrons more.
It turns out it's the zinc.
And you might say,
well, but wait a second.
If I just take an
electron out of here,
won't it be harder
than one out of here,
because this only has 4s1?
The answer is yes,
but I'm taking 2.
I'm not taking 1.
I'm talking about the
oxidation state of 2 plus.
That's going to be harder here.
It's harder to
take a 4s1 in a 3d
from that beautifully
filled 3d shell than it
is to take these 2s electrons.
That's why that's higher.
That's why that's hire, right.
So what you can see is that
the potential difference
is all about chemistry, right.
The delta v is all
about the chemistry.
It's all about all of the
things that we've learned.
It's more than that
because of these solutions,
so it's more
complicated than that,
but at the core of all of this
is all the topics that we've
learned, how strongly are
electrons bound to an atom,
to a metal, right.
And so well, if I took
cobalt, what would happen?
If I took cobalt
instead of copper,
the voltage here would be 1/2.
And you can sort of
look at the table
and think about why that is.
Cobalt has a 4s2
but it's got less
d electrons, and so is
it going to be easier
or harder to pull them out?
Well, it's going to
be easier than copper
but harder than zinc so it
goes in the middle, right.
And so the potential difference
is less for cobalt and zinc
but you still get a potential.
And so that's what
Volta did, and he did
all sorts of different metals.
And you can understand why zinc
and copper does this but copper
and zinc doesn't.
That's copper in
the zinc solution.
That's zinc in the
copper solution.
Nothing happens.
The reason is the potential.
It's just this.
It's just literally the
potential difference
that we just drew.
This is going to
be easier to take.
So I'm not going to go
the other way, right.
I'm not going to
go the other way,
so nothing happens
when you do that.
And then finally, the
last kind of piece of this
is that we need a reference
because you can only
get the changes in potentials.
It's like enthalpy.
You can only get the
changes, not the absolute,
so you've got to have
a standardization.
And the standardization
in the world of batteries
is hydrogen. So
what you do when you
think about battery
potentials is you write down
all of these reduction--
reduction is gaining electrons,
right-- you write down all.
It doesn't matter.
You could write reduction,
you could write oxidation.
They're just a flip
of the sign, right.
It's just a flipped
sign of the potential,
but what you write
these down with respect
to a common electrode,
and it's the standard.
It's called the standard
hydrogen electrode.
So sometimes you'll see it as
the SHE in the battery world.
And what it is it's just a
very nice platinum electrode
that doesn't change.
So it doesn't plate
or lose atoms.
And it's a reaction
that on that electrode
happens with hydrogen,
hydrogen gas.
And so what you do is you
hook this up on one side.
You hook that up on one side,
and then you put all the metals
against that.
And you measure their potential.
What's so powerful about
the SHE is that now I've
got all of these with respect
to the same reference, right?
So now when I look at
my zinc-copper battery,
well, it's just the difference
between those that's
the potential of the battery.
So hydrogen electrodes
gives you that ability
to standardize it and
create huge tables.
And if you look up
potentials of reduction,
they're all related to hydrogen.
You get thousands of them.
How much does somebody want
to lose, how many electrons?
That's going to be
in these tables.
And it's by a setup that is very
similar to the one I showed you
that is related to hydrogen. OK.
Or you could go the other way.
If I had zinc--
I just showed you zinc.
Copper in zinc doesn't happen
because it's the wrong sign.
But then what if I put
copper-- instead of in zinc,
I put copper in silver.
So there's copper in
zinc, copper in silver.
It works.
Because now silver is down here.
How did I know that?
Because I hooked it
up to hydrogen and I
compared it to copper.
And so that's how you
do battery chemistry is
you look things up.
You look up these
potentials in tables,
and you think about
which voltage you need.
And that gets us to
this Nobel Prize.
You say, well, why are lithium--
why did the Nobel
Prize go to the--
not discovery but the
development of lithium ions
as a storage technology?
And the reason is this.
You saw-- it was the highest
one on the list, too.
Look at that.
So now, I don't know what
the potential of a lithium
something battery
is going to be,
but I'm starting out with
a pretty negative voltage
with respect to
hydrogen. That makes
you think you might get
high voltages, and you do.
Yeah, but you have another
thing that's really cool
about lithium is
how light it is.
And those things combined
make it a beautiful battery
technology.
And that's why the
Nobel Prize was given.
Because if you look at
it on a plot like this,
it's all the way up here, if
you look at energy density
versus volume.
And a lithium battery works
much the same way in the sense
that you have the
separator here.
That's the electrolyte.
But now it's rechargeable.
And I don't have time to go
into rechargeable batteries
versus what are called
primary batteries, which
is the one I showed you.
But all the chemistry
is the same.
You're shuttling
ions back and forth.
You've got that
external circuit.
And what I wanted
to-- and there's
a whole bunch of chemistry.
So what has exploded
in the last--
well, that's a bad
word for batteries
because that is a danger
with lithium batteries.
[LAUGHTER]
But what has really
made the field take off
is you know the word.
We're in the class.
It's chemistry.
Because the flexibility
of where you
can put that other electrode
and what properties
it has gives you enormous room.
That's why lithium-ion batteries
can go in everything now,
all the way up to the grid.
And that was my last
Why This Matters
in the last 2 and 1/2 minutes.
This is the grid now.
So we went from
small to very big.
The growth in solar and
wind has been incredible
over the last 10, 20 years.
The problem, as I think I've
shown you, is the variability.
And so this is like--
if you zoom in here, that's
the load, the black line.
And this is what these
two resources give you.
And you can see that
it doesn't match.
If you zoom in on a day, then
you really can see it, right?
There is the load.
And there's what you would
get from solar and wind.
And so here's the question.
I said, well, OK,
how do you fix this?
You got to store it.
There's no way to use
renewables at large scales
unless you store it.
In fact, we're really at
essentially the tipping point.
Because if I look at the
countries in the world and what
their SPV penetration is-- and
this is a couple years old,
but it's still pretty
much the same--
Germany, Greece,
Italy at the top.
Sad frowny face here
for the US of A.
But Germany is at 7.1%
as of a few years ago.
That's a huge penetration of PV.
Well, here's the problem.
If you look at--
this is Germany, now.
Huge penetration-- these
are these six years,
seven years of adding PV.
This is how much they had.
They're now at 7%.
2016 is 7%.
This is how much the
price of electricity
was in Germany when they added.
So notice that here
is the sunlight
electricity during the day.
They can sell it
for a lot of money.
But as they add more and more
of this renewable to the grid,
its price goes down
when it's available.
In fact, it's now not
economical for them
to add more PV unless they
can add it with storage.
Because actually the price
has gone down so much
and it's gone up
here when they're not
generating any PV electricity.
So you can come up with--
and they did in this paper--
this sort of value factor
which, when it goes below 1,
means there's no economic
outcome that's positive here.
You can't make money any more.
And look at where that happens.
It's right around
where they are.
It's at 5%.
You can't solve renewables
at the scale of the grid
without storage.
And no option exists today.
It might be batteries.
It might be
batteries, but there's
nothing that actually does
it today at the scales
that we need.
So that's a real
challenge for chemistry.
And I hope you guys have a great
Thanksgiving and maybe hook
up some different metals.
And I'll see you all next week.